so this is Topsy turby and in order to
get a topsy turby effect that's
mechanically efficient I have to
establish a relationship between one end
of the lever and the other end of the
lever the two distal ends of the lever
you do that by establishing the center
and then you manipulate those distal
ends of the lever as far as possible in
the Topsy turbia effect so that's one
thing and then the other thing is you're
going to maintain connection with him so
that his weight will pull you over okay
and that's an adhesion all right so you
get you know you have to
depost
okay and here's one side of the lever up
here at the head and down here at this
foot okay and then the other side of the
lever is here but if I try to do this
his Center is kind of gooy what I want
to do is bring him on to me that makes I
don't know why but people tense okay and
they tense just enough and I've taken
weight off of there but if he was like
super Slinky Slinky then you'll feel
like ah man that's heavy again okay so
it's more than there's just weight off
his knees okay you want you as you move
people will stiffen up and now now this
works okay and then I maintain
connection so I do my scissors sweep and
as he goes over just whever I'm touching
without locking up his
weight will pull me
over okay let's try it is very
tempting to uh go just do a like a a a
cap on this and then you push him over
with
that okay then but we want to work both
ends of the lever so I'm going to move
this it's going all the way over
there even if I smell that he's
going I still still do it all the
way
okay don't get
lazy that's
got so even even as I'm holding him I'm
in that connection with him okay so as
he some people go one leg at a time they
start to stand you see I don't want to
contest this movement I'll I'll fall
into where I need to go and that's where
you're going to find the scissors sweep
okay and then you can
see if because you want to move the
distal ends as much as possible you have
to get to the distal end don't short
change it in here you were you stayed
attached to that point Let It Drop and
then you can see how much he's ready to
fall this way okay yes sir so doesn't
take as much as the administrative
version to get these relationships and
now you just do the same scissors sweep
stay
connected so you you maintain connection
he goes it's going to move you it moves
you you go he moves
you okay let him move
he
goes moves me this part over here okay
don't pull it down you're moving it
forward all the adhering here adhering
here moves him forward you see that it's
not going down moveing
forward that's where you get
it cuz he's going to be you're going to
be trying to get up
okay once you touch the back of his neck
he's going to be trying to get it up so
let's get
there okay once you grab his neck he he
he's going to feel that precariousness
so as he goes up you don't want to hold
here you don't want to clench down on
that as he goes up you taking it that
way okay just
like uh when he gets up here you know I
don't try to shove it down I bring It
Forward same exact
thing I'm I'm light wherever I'm
touching
him light he tries to get up I'm
bringing it
Forward okay otherwise you got to be
stronger than okay here we
go back to admin pendulum sweep okay you
got a couple choices you can either go
on the hip you can go on the
leg but you're going to try to turn 90°
to
him you can use your arm to come in okay
and what you want is this knee in the
armpit so keep your locks in there but
here's the part you do have to have that
arm in there okay so he doesn't post out
the bottom leg keeps straight cuz it's
going to attack the distal end of the
pendulum at the
bottom at the
end and you'll come
over keep this leg straight so you don't
make him land on you so
boom again bring him on you then start
to sweep you can keep this long this leg
so you get a good base and when you're
ready
then you take it
out stay connected so when the center of
gravity moves it moves you
too okay let's try
sir okay so any Topsy Turvy that you do
in a single plane so in the vertical
plane that as much mechanical advantage
as you have by working in the distal
ends of the lever that still requires a
great deal of energy if you make this
Topsy Turvy thing travel across the mat
in the sagittal plane it takes less
energy okay so we were doing that in the
other one if you posts up here and when
I brought him this way you see he's
traversing if he stays here and I try to
flip this it's doable but that takes way
more energy than if I'm bringing it this
way then it's effortless okay so the
more ples you add especially the
sagittal one the less energy it takes to
make the two distal ends trade places
all right so same thing here when you
come around here you don't you want to
make him Traverse okay so this leg is
I'm going to game this leg this leg is
actually bringing him this way
when you add the arm and the hook and
everything it's much easier I'm going to
bring him this way you
see not this
way so bring him on you and he goes this
way much
easier
Okay add that sagittal plan try it again
in all your techniques right so find
doing EO uh and he's going to try to
resist up it's not that I drop on him
and try to take him down okay the energy
that he resists going up I take
forward okay every every technique's
like that so this is no
different okay so a guy is trying to get
up a lot of people shoot you should get
up you shouldn't stay down there's no
you have no business staying seated in a
closed guard okay okay but some people
make the mistake of getting up one leg
at a time or you you're making it hard
for him to get up one leg to get up both
legs at the time whatever the reason if
one leg comes
up you're going to look for the
precariousness that comes from
transitioning from his knee to his foot
okay that's what I'm looking for and
when I take that precariousness I'm not
trying to hold it down
as he goes to stand up this motion is
going forward on the neck and then the
knee pull is going forward okay and as
he starts to go up I'm going to take him
to the
side so that I get the side scissor get
my elbow Out start climbing on the back
he's not going to let me do that he's
going to try to get his head up and
start pushing back and now here
is your pendulum sweep
again don't contest anything directly he
goes one there it is Boom up here he
comes
Bo
pendulum okay try it again